tonight correspondent Kevin cork at the
White House on the short-term
consequences of president Trump's trade
policy in announcing the company would
shift production of some of its
motorcycles to the European Union to
avoid new EU tariffs harley-davidson
today slammed the brakes on a key White
House narrative that protectionism by
way of tariffs saves American jobs the
move comes after the Trump
administration hit the EU with tariffs
of 25 percent on steel and 10 percent on
aluminum in retaliation the EU began
charging import duties on a range of US
products including motorcycles in
Harley's case that meant raising from 6
percent to 31 percent the tariffs per
imported Harley in its filings with the
SEC the Wisconsin company suggested that
this was an unintended consequence of an
aggressive trade policy by the white
house calling its decision the only
sustainable option to make its
motorcycles accessible to customers in
the EU but White House officials place
blame for the tariff dispute squarely at
the feet of the EU the European Union is
trying to punish us workers because
they've engaged repeatedly in unfair
trade practices and the president is
saying enough is enough we'd like to
work with the EU to work on a level
playing field
Sanders comments reflect an increasingly
aggressive posture by the administration
Commerce Secretary Wilbur Ross saying
that the days of quote spoiling US trade
partners are over and Treasury Secretary
Stephen minuchin warning that proposed
investment restrictions on some American
companies will target all countries that
are trying to steal our technology a not
so veiled reference to China economists
believe the trade war could spread
consuming the auto industry next where
the president has already threatened to
hit European car makers with a stock
market rattling 20% import fee and the
short term it's not good for Trump the
one thing is the markets don't like
tariffs the market loves Trump but the
markets don't like tariffs so we're
seeing this immediate negative reaction
and it could last for the next few days
borrowing a last-minute deal the u.s. is
set to hit China with another thirty
four billion dollars in tariffs in July
right Kevin cork at the White House
Kevin thank you